an assassin's creed syndicate you will
become the leader of London's fiercest
gang and use your power to fight against
exploitation Industrial Revolution
London is a city overflowing with
excitement and danger it is packed full
of opportunities for players to grow and
command a street army filled with the
toughest brutes and all along everything
you do in the open world will not only
support your rise to power as the gang
leader but also affect your entire
gaming experience a gang leaders
progression is based on three crucial
factors taking territory making money
and growing the might and power of your
gang the more territory you acquire the
larger number of allies you'll have on
the streets the more you invest in your
gang the more versatile they'll be in
assisting you by amassing a robust gang
army more strategies are opened up to
you when it comes time to complete other
missions Onion Knight a mix of
disenfranchised outsiders and a one-name
we can rally them to our site we'll call
ourselves the rooks
creating London's fiercest criminal
organization isn't cheap so you'll need
money to grow your gang income
activities are ways of earning cash for
gang and gear upgrades punch your way
through fight clubs working your way
through the rounds of ever tougher
opponents to claim the highest rewards
we have a new charge your carriage
through the streets of London racing
against rivals for money bored
adversaries trains and carriages and
fight enemies at blazing speeds white
steal valuable cargo and select gazing
into the future raid other gangs boats
or sabotage their supply lines to
disrupt their operations you and your
family are safe Thank You mr. all of
these income activities fill your bank
account but to increase your control of
the city you will need to complete
conquest activities as you build your
reputation you'll need to prove yourself
by helping associates who know the
secrets to defeating your rival gangs
and taking their territory for yourself
over the is I have established a number
of connections across the city as you
help the associates you'll be rewarded
with new weapons gear and tools
expanding your territorial dominance in
the process there's a this moment you
all work for us
make rival gangs think twice before
setting foot on your turf put the
pressure on their leaders by kidnapping
them and turning them over to the
authorities scream as we lost track down
the Templars pulling the gang strings
and assassinate them in unique ways to
send their allies a message
take over rival gang strongholds to
claim their territory and free or fellow
rooks once you've completed every
conquest mission in a burrow all hell
breaks loose and the gang war begins
this bara is oz for the taking Street by
street prob I borough fight to take back
London welcome to the family Assassin's
Creed syndicate join the family get
rewards reserved now for exclusive
access to the Darwin and Dickens
conspiracy available october twenty
third